the Joe Rogan experience but yeah if you
someone we find you know that favors
right or that there's an you know this
there's this contact know suddenly guess
what we had that's that's it that's the
top concern at that that's number one
right right yeah I mean the hope is
always that if we're about to nuke
ourselves into another dimension that
the aliens have come down it domains
just like a 1950's movie yeah The Day
the Earth Stood Still yeah yeah to
Barada nikto Wow remember that look at
you yeah that's pretty impressive
actually
daily Earth Stood Still is a great
[ __ ] movie it was a great movie it's
weird it's like a time capsule right
because what they what they thought it
would look like and yeah the robot
that's just ya know it is I love the
movie I tried to get my boys to sit and
watch it not too long ago they're like
really dad
this is what you spend your time
watching it was interesting I was like a
normal thing that the family took the
alien in their house yeah come on in
stay with a strange person another land
why wouldn't you yeah was talking to the
kid like you don't you know anyone who's
a little suspicious I think this guy
might be a freak
what's your favorite movie it's sort of
alien space yanma movie well I like the
best one is alien the Sigourney Weaver
movie I think first one yeah that's most
likely what alien life is gonna be like
some horrific parasitic [ __ ] creature
that eats everything it finds yeah
that's that to me seems likely yeah that
seems more likely I remember sitting in
the theater when that movie came out
watching it and when that when it popped
out of that guy's chest he was you know
I mean the entire theater jumped yeah it
was just crazy but people it's hard
because you you watch that movie today
and you're watching it having seen all
the other movies that it's affected and
all the other science fiction genre
movies and special effects movies but
that movie was special yeah in 1979 when
that movie came out that was a special
movie that was a [ __ ] horrific ly
scary movie and it was realistic like
there was no cut the [ __ ] scenes
everything seemed legitimate the
creature was completely unique Weaver
was hot hot as [ __ ] yeah
no I mean let's see that's pictures that
literally we should be looking at so no
ever and now it's a great movie where a
woman is the hero and you're not you're
not flinching you're not there's no part
where you go what what is she doing
she's kicking everybody's ass get the
[ __ ] out of here that's that's a movie
like like that's a real hero
yeah that's a real hero who rises to the
occasion in this horrific situation
where this ship has have been overtaken
by an alien I think that there's I think
that there's things out there I don't
know if I believe I want to believe that
we've been visited but I don't know if I
believe I think there's things out there
yeah I I'm on board with what the second
part of that as well I I don't know I I
find it hard to believe it would be such
a secret but you know and also knowing
the US government look I mean you know
you know it's it's harder to find out
from the network when they're gonna
start this show than this getting
secret's out of Washington DC right so
I'm thinking yeah we would have known
for now if it had happened but I do
believe this other [ __ ] out there right
I just I can't believe we're it no I
don't leave I don't you know I don't
think we're but maybe we're being
hopeful I can't believe for it I mean
but you know but I'm also fascinated to
think that if they did know that there's
something that something was here that
they would visit it occasionally you
know drop in on it occasionally and for
a scientific expedition just see what
the [ __ ] were up to yeah unless they
just got so disgusted the last time they
just thought that's it we don't get
disgusted when we go visit baboons when
we study baboons you know people
scientists return you know Robert
Sapolsky he spent many years going back
and forth to Africa studying baboons and
baboons are boring as [ __ ] of many
people if you weren't a person if you
were in a person if you were for some
from some enlightened the race a million
years advanced for us you'd be so fast
and to come by and look at people yeah
although they probably look at us like
we're a bunch of [ __ ] flinging monkey so
thank you probably right yeah I mean
wouldn't if we had a time machine tell
me you wouldn't be amazing if there was
a time machine but it could only go back
five hundred thousand year
to go to the beginning of man like the
early I you know whatever ancient
hominid that was that was a lot back
then god damn that would be fascinating
be a fly on the wall and watch these
primitive humanoids try to figure out
fire and try to figure out hunting and
and become what we are today yeah yeah
there were probably moments right now I
wouldn't want to sit and watch the whole
thing because I think that would be you
know boring as [ __ ] I mean come on just
get on with it you know chip that rock
into a circle do something with it come
on but but I think that yeah you're
right I mean I think if there's if
there's higher life-forms out there and
let you'd have to assume they are higher
life-forms if they're traveling you know
these distances and we again looking at
this issues of propulsion systems for
hypersonic flight excetera you know
would they look at this bunch of you
know folks down here and think just not
interested I don't know and I think at a
certain point in time it would be
unnecessary to physically visit mmm I
feel like maybe watching us through the
Samsung TVs yeah I see it all comes and
that's the thing about it all comes back
around full circle
[Applause]